this is Troye Sivan and I'm in isolation
in my parents house in Melbourne in
their spare bedroom and I'm about to
play truth or whine I have a nice
nondescript wine I actually don't know
what this is I still look for my parents
and we'll see how much I have to drink
of it what was the most recent text
exchange you've had with Ariana Grande
let me see how salacious this is oh
that's not that bad it was that guess
the get rich name that everyone is doing
on Instagram
one of the ones is is her name here
macaroon though that's me trying to say
her name and so I sent that to her and
we were laughing about it what is the
last photo saves your camera roll
interesting question um honestly okay
it's a screenshot I'm not gonna show you
with it
I'm just gonna flash up like one second
of a DM with a company that I really
really like their product and I was like
you know what I'm just gonna try it and
I message them saying like I didn't ask
for anything but I was like I love your
product just to see what would happen
and I think they're gonna send me some
last year you revealed your celebrity
crush with Shawn Mendes is the crush
still alive I've got to be real the
crush sort of faded because he and
Camilla started going out and Camille is
a very good friend of mine and I I don't
know it just started feeling a little
strange to like publicly a thirst for a
friend's boyfriend I was just like I'm
not it's not a thing do you have a fin
star or an alt social media account I do
I don't use it though I use the close
friends feature a lot on Instagram now I
used to have a fin say and I actually
hated it I had it for like two weeks
maybe I used it and then I just got
really over it and it wasn't fun so yeah
but I do use close friends alone who is
the biggest name celebrity you've
written song about
I'm gonna drink for that one definitely
gonna drink on that one is there a video
from your early youtuber days you wish
you could scope from the internet almost
all of them like I wish I had them on
private so that I could watch them and
like show my kids one day God there is
some really awful stuff up there which
song of yours do you think deserves more
love from the general public I'm just
gonna sit my wine just cuz I want to
it's really good I wish my mum I got a
little more love I think that that would
have been fun for me but I mean I'm like
so stoked with how everything web if you
were gonna party with Charli XCX what
would you bring to the pregame tapas
have you ever slid into a fans DMS 100%
but that sounds bad it wasn't like that
like I I deal with people all the time
so no not like that
in all honesty no why did you delete
between hashtag pops about bottoming out
there single gloom was released my mom
is Twitter I mean it didn't work she saw
it both of my parents had Twitter
actually and I'm pretty sure they have
me on tweet notifications if I ever
delete stuff half the time it's because
I'm worried about those two people
rather than the other however many
people do you have any unreleased songs
with other artists if so with who duets
like not really I have written a lot
with other artists Rufus Wainwright we
did a song that never came out Mark
Ronson and I have worked a couple times
Julia Michaels and I have worked a bunch
I don't know there's like plenty of
people I've also pitched a lot of songs
to artists to like very little success a
lot of artists have my demos like on
their phones or whatever and some of
them cut the songs and some of them
didn't but yeah if you could guest star
on any TV show which so would you pick
what TV shows have I been enjoying
recently I don't know can I go back in
time I was gonna say friends just cuz
it's like such a cultural moment like I
remember when people used to guest our
own friends like the Brad Pitt episode
of friends is literally singed into my
brain like I can picture him now so I
guess that cuz it's like such a moment
what was the inspiration behind your
single take yourself home I think I was
just like kind of in a bad place at the
time of writing it I was just feeling
really like unsettled and lonely
like yeah I just kind of had this moment
where I had to have a really honest
conversation with myself for I was like
really waiting almost everything in my
life and so I wrote it into this song
and then the crazy thing is that like
now with everything that's going on in
the world I feel like a lot of people
are having to do that right now and have
those conversations and be like wait
whoa like everything has been pulled out
from under me right now what is actually
important to me what makes me happy who
makes me happy you know one of the
things that I'm gonna stop taking for
granted like you know all of those kind
of questions and conversations that
you're having with yourself I think it's
all kind of like in the song is take
yourself home as standalone single or
part of an upcoming album to be released
I wouldn't say it's part of an album
it's part of a like project I know that
sounds so wanky but it's like longer
than an EP shorter than an album so I
don't know what you want to call it
what's one pop song you can't turn off
right now the honest answer owner this
is so lame but it is one of my demos I
got a new version yesterday so I've been
listening to it like to kind of suss out
how I'm feeling about all of the
production changes and I'm really really
really excited about it if you could
only listen to one pop Queens
discography for the rest of your life
whose would you choose mmm
Robin right I mean like I feel like
that's the correct answer
like what else could you say you know I
feel like she would just keep me on my
toes here we keep me interested Robin
Michelle can i brag about one quick
thing speaking of close friends the
other day Robin took me on her close
friends list on Instagram and it was
like literally I would say the number
one highlight of my entire life so far
so I did just want to brag for a second
about that thank you for having me I
hope you learned a little bit about me I
will by choice finish this class right
now but stay safe stay home I have a new
song out called take the cell phone and
I'm also selling t-shirts actually and
all the proceeds are going towards co-ed
relief so go to my website Troye Sivan
comm I love you guys thanks for watching